it's a very difficult complicated
subject as I've listened to the comments
one of the things that I think is has to
be asked is I kind of it's not it's not
a critique of public service as a thing
but it's a it's a question Deo has said
there's huge number of NGOs working in
Burundi this person says where's the
sort of the proof that this actually
works you respond we've got to focus on
that Judy says we're really working on
trying to make sure that the things work
the lack the problems of lack of
coordination the problems of overdoing
expertise and not listening the problems
of sort of massive amounts of programs
that may not add up to is this just an
inevitable part of a vast culture of
public service that you're just always
going to have this to the degree we have
or is there actually something in the
nature of public service that could make
it more effective and and what might
those be so it relates to your question
your question was really how come if all
of this has been going on for so long
things aren't better and I think that's
the that that is the fundamental
question and you gave one answer and
that is a critical answer I don't think
that there has been many of these
programs aren't set up to measure
themselves to achieve impact they're set
up to make you feel good and you really
feel good when you're doing it if you do
measure you often measure outputs rather
than outcomes so and often volunteerism
is aggregated on your schedule when it's
convenient for you I think I'll go for
the semester or and then what happens
over Christmas break and so but that's
not how problems live on the world they
live on our calendars so it's both the
program's themselves which often don't
hold themselves to achieve impact the
individuals who were working in them who
scheduled in public service according to
their convenient and I'm not being
pejorative I'm really exactly I've we've
been trying to analyze this because that
is the sixty-four-thousand-dollar
question why aren't the problem solved
we have all these things going on lots
of people lots of money lots of time new
problems arise so clearly that's one
part of the answer but as we've
disaggregated it the things that i've
just reviewed and maybe many others or
another piece of the answer and so you
need to systematically look at this and
address all of these ways that these
these efforts could improve yeah in
order to finally perhaps solve problems
you also need to get to the root causes
a lot of what we're doing in public
service as my founder john d rockefeller
called it we're putting band-aids on
weeping wounds and we're not getting to
the fundamental causes of the problems
and the only way ultimately to solve
them so that they don't recur is to
solve the root cause and a lot of
intervention is not doing that dammit
right
so many so many Ivy League's Harvard yo
you know they they live with them maybe
they do better semester they do they
volunteer service and then they're gone
you know but the last six years I've
been living in an unnamed neighborhood
in Brooklyn and I've seen my presence
actually being in the community making a
difference and the kind of work that
I've been doing there I I really believe
that NGOs or other programs academic
institutions that are working with the
you know somewhere within the community
I should be careful about this we are
they working with the community or
within the community and I think it is
extremely important to first figure out
where my why am I doing this in speaking
of the from the me generation to the
regeneration are we actually doing a
service for example for ourselves or for
the community and if is for the
community are we getting the community
involved for example I I'd like to
mention the example of village
earthworks in Burundi because you know
when we started we actually i was in
Burundi and the someone was sick and
that someone turned out to be my own
mother and I saw a lot of people who
were detained because they could not pay
for medical bills just that and I hadn't
no money I had nothing but I hear
friends and I said what can we do well
you know everyone is the gosh this is
horrible this is the blah blah blah so
you have people who can choose to run
away because too much you have other
people who are horrified and we'll see
well we need to do something and in
reckoned some of my friends so I talk to
community members in they said well how
about if we actually set up a tent here
if I have friends who are you know
clinicians or or anyone could come and
see you from right here instead of being
cursorily or having all these problems
they got so excited these are people who
have less than nothing in terms of
financial support or but they hardly can
be really guided where they start making
bricks of course they you know many of
them do not have the knowledge the rain
came thousands of breaks boom just a
mile so I went back in the you know talk
to friends and would raise seven hundred
dollars 700 years does send that money
back in were able to buy food for people
they made a lot of you know breaks and
they were really engaged so the
community will owns the project they
have the ownership they participate and
that is how really were able to to to
really get done what we've been able to
get done now who do we actually get
involved it's really interesting to see
you know when you are in the community
there are visible thing about themselves
narratives the thing about community how
actually do you think about yourself or
how do you think about community
sometimes unfortunately it's human
nature you think about yourself pays
only personal experiences and this is I
think the reason why for example we got
a lot of women we create this committee
a committee of men ten men end in the
twelve women this is an important lead
in the place that is what it is and in
turn I said well we can work together
like that that committee turns out to be
something quite interesting the men were
talking the women were listening when it
was about to do the work only the women
were showing up why
why because health care in Burundi
women's health that is like another
language neglected every woman you see
with the child on her back is a
suffering like an animal dying on the
side of the road and why were they
participating more than anyone else the
committee of men disappeared we had one
man left I asked him lecture what I
couldn't join the Women's Committee nuh
said fine the meanwhile the committee of
women kept growing because we really
talked to them say well these are issues
have the issues programs so oh actually
are we talking about the people who are
suffering and without them involved they
really have been so involved in building
the clinic and this is exactly how you
find out exactly what are the needs and
I think of we you know NGOs and other
people the program's really fails simply
because they really do not listen they
don't observe yeah just experts you have
nothing to teach me I've learned in the
expert listen to me and Andy see what
you see that's my mail my opinion about
that should we how close are we
one more this
I just wondered whether as a part of the
community the seniors in the community
they are people i think that's a source
that's been under tapped and those
people have time and they have ability
and particularly if they've attended the
schools here and they would like to be
utilized and i think they're untapped i
just want to do you have a group in your
organization that could organize that
utilize all this from the retirement can
meet the our community app absolutely so
i actually a partner with AARP on a wide
range of initiatives I kind of I've now
learned to go to them say this is going
to launch how can you help me they have
a great website create the good and
we're able to work with them I mean it
has been phenomenal we also have worked
with the New York foundation preceding
citizens and one of my initiatives is
actually with the Department for the
aging so I an answer to your question we
realize this is an untapped resource and
one thing you know I figured out is that
ask the experts on how to engage this
community and not try to come up with
the answer myself and I think we've been
some of those initiatives I've mentioned
that have been oversubscribed a good bit
of our volunteers have have been from
the senior population so Dale Judy Diane
thank you very very much
you